now Bastille Day Celebrations are
underway in France India's prime
minister Narendra Modi as guest of honor
at the traditional parade in Paris to
honor the French Revolution tens of
thousands of police are on duty
Nationwide following recent rise in the
killing of a teenager by a police
officer let's bring in our correspondent
Natasha Butler who's following those
celebrations in Paris and of course
France pulling out all the stops for
this guest of honor that they're trying
to get on the right side of economically
and geopolitically
yes that's right a bit earlier we saw
the French President Emmanuel macron
traveling on top of a military vehicle
down the chandelier and then greeting
India's prime minister Narendra Modi who
is the guest of honor for these Bastille
Day Celebrations now the Elyse Aces this
is about trying to expand its
relationship with India it's also of
course about economics and trade and
India is expected uh to buy more
french-made fighter jets from France now
Emmanuel macron says that India is a
close partner and it must work closely
uh with it but we do know as well that
many have said that what France is doing
is what other Western Powers have been
doing recently and that is courting
India in order to try and counter
growing Chinese influence in the region
that's particularly important for France
that has territories in the indo-pacific
region but look not everyone is happy
about Modi being here for these Bastille
Day Celebrations they say it's
inappropriate to roll out the red carpet
for a leader they say who since 2014
along with his Hindu nationalist party
has seen a deterioration of human rights
in India particularly with more
persecution they say of minorities
including Christians and Muslims and of
course you're closer to home security
must have been tightened up considering
recent events
well indeed because these uh Bastille
Day Celebrations are three-day public
holiday come less than two weeks after
French uh police officer shot dead a
teenager in a Paris suburb really not
that far from here I have to say that
sparked several nights of violence the
French government certainly do not want
to see a repeat of those sort of scenes
uh on in uh in France so what they've
done is they have deployed a huge amount
of police officers 130
000 officers across the country over
these three days in order to try and
keep the peace because what they don't
want is scenes of violence Marin the
French public holiday
Natasha Butler therefore is in Paris
thank you